the Trump administration's revived
travel ban is in effect this morning but
faces a new legal challenge some
protesters gathered last night at Los
Angeles International Airport and other
major US airports as a partial ban took
effect now it limits entry for people
from six mostly Muslim countries
travelers from those nations must have a
close family member in the US or be
coming here for school or a job Kris Van
Cleave is at Dulles International
Airport that's just outside Washington
without the definition of close family
member is facing some criticism now Kris
good morning good morning think back to
January and the chaos and confusion that
was happening here at Dulles and at
airports across the country we're not
seeing that this morning now instead
people with a visa are still able to
come to the US but now there's a legal
battle brewing over what constitutes
bona fide family most Muslims feel that
this isn't the best way to promote peace
the Trump administration's new visa
rules or so called travel ban did not
prompt the protest at the nation's
airports we saw in January but the
executive orders narrow definition of a
family is already prompting a legal
battle it does affect people it does
tear parent families apart earlier this
week the Supreme Court partially revived
the ban but allowed visas to be granted
to travelers from the six countries if
they have a closed familial relationship
with someone in the US the State
Department to find that close
relationship as a parent in law's a
spouse a child or a sibling and late
last night the government added fiancee
but brothers and sisters in law
grandparents grandchildren aunts and
uncles are not considered by the
government to be close the State
Department is defending that decision we
received the family definition from
federal law and we received the family
definition and for whatever reason it
doesn't include grandparents but we were
just going along with what federal law
states I was raised by my grandparents
so the idea of grandparents not being
part of a family is very foreign to me
last night Hawaii asked a district judge
to stop enforcing the ban and a more
clearly explained what makes a bona fide
relationship civil liberties groups say
they are anticipating further legal
challenges we feel like we're gonna keep
winning to be missed and we're not gonna
get sick of waiting there are other
exceptions to the executive order that
includes people with direct business
ties to the US journalists adopted
children and people seeking urgent
medical attention here in the US the
Supreme Court is set to hear arguments
on this new executive order in the fall
David thank you Chris